it's been a lot of fun playing the grand
Chester so far it's been to my favorite
tournaments in Norway chess and also the
sink to cup my experience competing in
the grand chester has been pretty good
so far I've come very close to winning
in both events and I've had stable
results certainly going to the third
event I have a good chance to
potentially win the whole thing overall
haven't won any of the two tournaments
so this might be my chance I was not
happy with my player on my result and I
had a tough start but hopefully I can
recover in this final like I had a much
better result in Norway then st. Louis
but I hope to do well yeah well it's
been very interesting to watch the
tomans from home and it's great to take
part in it all so far it couldn't have
been better of course I'm still a leader
but this is like the final tournament
for sure it will be very tough I'm
pretty much sure that the winner here
will be also the overall winner
Francesco well so far I've had quite a
lot of fun I mean it's always great to
play against these guys and I don't
think anyone has a guarantee to be a
favourite in this kind of event so far
for most of the players everything is
still open and I believe the person who
wins this tournament is most likely to
be the overall winner anyway it's really
gonna come down to who finishes I think
in first and second place my results
haven't been too good so I'm hoping to
redeem myself here in